a unique police fire or medical  service 8 news now investigators the  9-1-1 call a 28-year-old Woman made  after she reportedly killed her mother  inside their South Valley Home good  evening thanks for joining us at 11 I'm  Denise Valdez now in that call police  say 28-year-old hen bustami calmly  described how she killed her mother  before hanging up now we do want to warn  you the details might be disturbing  why do you think you killed your mom  because I did I I murdered her how did  you do that  as our 8 news now investigators first  reported last week bustami told police  she used shards of glass on a broken  table to allegedly stab her mother after  describing what happened bustami hung up  police in California later arrested her  just outside of Barstow 61-year-old afaf  husanin reportedly told friends that she  was concerned for her safety